we need to do something about it it's
dangerous for us now there are chunks of
my childhood black holes black spaces I
asked her how far back does this go and
she said
it goes all the way back
[Music]
is a church founded in 1926. anywhere
you name it there's a church of the
light of the world La luzen Mundo claims
to have 5 million members in 57
countries one of the largest religious
cults of our time in addition to the
yachts and the cars they have ranches in
Texas in California the church has one
leader at a time and that's the Apostle
there have been three Apostles in the
same family with three generations of
abuse that have been covered up till now
that wanted to prove that I was worthy
they almost make it seem romantic and
like a fairy tale you're going to be a
princess he hit me until I fell I hope
that his Mercy for anything he wanted
you might think it's a sin but it's not
because it's in the presence of the
Apostle they cut
ties with your family my mother she
to me you're pretty familiar
to remain anonymous is the fear if
something happens to me my daughter or
my husband it's coming from them this
isn't a church this is some sort of
Mafia
first thing we think is exposure we've
got to expose it I started to reach out
to people in the United States everybody
in the metoo movement never got anything
back from anybody the Bibles has
maintained Justice and do what is right
this has to stop I think Fitness would
have been different if these were white
American girls we're going to get
Justice they have so much power it got
bigger everybody exposing this Beast
the truth is there
I could kiss myself it was never a
blessing I want to be a voice for all
the other little girls
[Music]